Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today,
I’m going to explain a science
fiction thriller film called “The Titan.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is based in 2048.
Several cars drive along the Atlantic ocean
to the NATO operating base. One of the cars stops
in front of a mansion. A woman shows a family of
three inside the mansion, which is now their new
home. The father, Rick Janssen, his wife, Dr.
Abigail Janssen, and his son, Lucas are surprised,
clearly not used to the lavishness of the place.
The three stand in front of their private swimming
pool, when Lucas asks Rick where he is going.
Ric shows him a direction towards the sky. The
camera pans out showing similar houses in the
neighborhood, suggesting that the people who came
in the other cars were given similar houses.
The next morning, Professor Martin
Collingwood visits the family.
The couple is happy to see him. Rick thanks the
professor for selecting him for the mission,
but the professor instead reminds him
of the risks involved in the mission.
The professor says he is grateful
for their service, and leaves.
Cut to a NATO conference. The
professor speaks in front of a group.
In the year 2048, the earth’s natural resources
have been used to their pieces. People begin to
fight for whatever remains of the resources, and
wars between the countries are prevalent.
He predicts that in ten years, half of the planet
will be uninhabitable, and in fifteen years,
half of the world’s current population will
starve to death. Human being’s time is running
out because they have outgrown their homes. The
professor claims that their children will witness
the end of the world. However, amidst all this,
he claims that there is hope, the hope being the
largest moon of Saturn named Titan. The only other
body besides Earth in the solar system that has an
atmosphere, making it the most inhabitable
body in the solar system besides the Earth.
But it is in no way ready to be inhabited by
humans. As liquid methane rains on the heavenly
body, the atmosphere is filled with nitrogen,
and the temperature is extremely low.
The professor claims, space science says
that Titan cannot be livable for humans
but he has a different approach. He wants to
use modern genetics to make people adapt to
the nature of the planet, rather than trying
to make the planet inhabitable for humans.
Hence, Rick and thirteen others in the team
have been called to be experimented upon to
make them adapt to the environment of Titan. He
claims, with little enhancements in their body,
they will be able to breathe nitrogen in its air
and survive the cold of Titan. Everyone there
knows of the risk of the experiment, but they
are willing to put their lives in danger, for the
future generation. Their main aim is to be able to
establish Titan as human’s new home planet.
The group has been chosen from five thousand
people in sixteen different countries for this
specific task, because of their ability to
survive. One person at the convention argues
that the process is a forced evolution and none of
them will survive in the end, but the others claim
they know of the risks. After the convention,
the group is given their respective key cards
and taken to a lab. The experiment’s helper, Dr.
Freya Upton, gives Rick a shot and informs him
that he will be getting over three hundred shots
in the next week. The shots are to train them
to burn nitrogen instead of oxygen for energy,
because the level of oxygen in Titan is only 5%,
which is less than earth’s 20%.
Cut to their mansions, all fourteen of
the volunteers and their families have been given
the lavish homes next to each other, hence Abigail
invites everyone for a barbecue weekend. They all
dance, eat and drink together. This is the last
time they will be allowed to drink alcohol, so
they enjoy it. Abigail is drunk after the party,
so Rick helps her get to their room; but before
they can, he begins to cough aggressively. Abigail
helps him and sees he is burning with fever. She
gives him some medicine and puts him to bed.
In the next experiment, the volunteers are
made to sit underwater for as long as they can.
The last ones inside are Rick and a girl
named Tally. The two have been underwater
for thirty-one minutes. Everyone outside is happy
and surprised that the experiments have worked.
Tally starts suffocating and goes to
the surface in thirty-nine minutes,
but Rick still stays inside. His vitals seem to
be dropping, so everyone gets worried. However,
Rick starts swimming across the pool
at great speed, showing his progress.
Everyone cheers and claps for him, he has
been underwater for forty-two minutes.
At night, Rick tells his son Lucas about
Titan’s conditions as a bedtime story.
The kid is thrilled to know that his father will
be able to live on another planet soon. Rick then
joins his wife in the swimming pool, where she
notices the nerves on his back being prominent.
She labels it as a side effect of the shots
he has been given, but is worried for him.
As time goes by, Abigail and Rayenne, the wife of
another volunteer, become friends. Rayenne tells
her that she didn’t want her husband to come here,
but he doesn’t listen to anything she says.
Rick goes through surgery that
day. Abigail, being a doctor,
reads the book they were given, that has
all the procedures Rick has to go through.
She sees that all of them are safe, so she is
relieved. At night, she wakes up, and notices that
Rick is missing from their bed. She goes to the
kitchen, and sees him applying ice on his body.
He says he was burning in their bed. Abigail
brings out a bucket of ice and Rick puts his hands
in there. He asks his wife to do the same, but she
brings her hands out, not bearing the cold. Rick
then claims that he cannot feel any cold. He has
adapted to live in Titan’s cold temperature.
In one experiment, the group is made to swim
underwater as the place is filled with methane
gas as it would be on Titan. Next, they are made
to run around a field for as long as they can,
while breathing methane and nitrogen. They do the
same exercise for several days. The group is in
the changing room, when Rick notices a lot of his
hair falling. Tally tries to see if it’s true and
gets a lump of hair out of his head. Just then,
one of the female volunteers vomits out blood and
falls on the ground struggling. The others try to
help her and call the officials. Dr. Freya tries
to help her, but she dies on the ground before she
can do anything. The group is shocked as the harsh
reality of the experiment is starting to show.
That night, everyone gathers at Rick’s home again
and discusses the matter. Abigail notices
all the volunteers’ nerves being prominent
for some seconds, and then disappearing,
although no one else seems to notice.
Rayenne and her husband are outside in the pool.
Her husband has been panicking because of the
death. As the others talk, he hits Rayenne on
her face and loses control. The others go to
help the girl, and restrain the man. His brain
has not been handling the experiments well.
The following day, Dr. Freya comes over
to Rick’s to test his vitals. She claims
that the girl who died has kidney stones which
altered the experiments, causing her to die.
At night, Rick cannot stop vomiting blood. Abigail
takes a sample of it to investigate it herself.
While shutting the doors, she sees
a light blinking from the walls,
and realizes that they are being watched. Rick
is in the swimming pool, when his skin starts
to peel off and float. Later when they sleep,
Abigail sees Rick’s back has peeled too.
Abigail takes the sample to the lab the
next morning, and sees that it has several
compounds that the book didn’t talk about.
The lab performs eye surgery on Rick that
day. It is to allow him to see through the
darkness. He goes home after the surgery,
but has to be rushed back to the hospital when
his eyes start to bleed uncontrollably.
Abigail meets the professor, and accuses him of
not telling them everything about the procedure.
She confronts him about the cameras
that he claims are for security reasons.
He dismisses her and sends her home. As
soon as she is home, she sees large army
vans arriving at Rayenne’s home. She rushes to
see what is happening, but a soldier stops her.
Just then, someone throws Rayenne out of the
window, her dead body is lying on the front porch.
Rayenne’s husband has gone completely
wild because of the experiments.
One night, Abigail takes Rick’s key
card and sneaks into the facility.
She finds the volunteers’ medical file and sees
that the girl who died didn’t have kidney stones.
The professor and the team are in a meeting with
NASA. The professor is chastised for doing forced
evolutionary experimentation without proper
evidence or ethical reasons. He is threatened
with having his operation shut down.
When the professor comes to visit Rick
at his home, he tells Abigail that he does not
actually know the effects of the experiments yet,
but they cannot go back now. The subjects will
be turned into a new species of humans called
the Homo Titaniens, and will be different from
Homo sapiens, but since everybody evolves in a
different way, they do not know what Rick
will turn to after the full experiment.
Later, Rick opens the bandage from his eyes
and is surprised to see everything around,
even in the dark. His eyes have evolved.
The following day, they perform a vital surgery on
the subjects, but all of them die except for Rick
and Tally. Now, the future of humanity lies on the
two. Abigail is brought to the facility after the
surgery, and is surprised to see her husband turn
into a different creature altogether. But it is
evident that he still remembers them. They have
turned completely into Homo Titaniens. They can
listen to the humans talking, but cannot talk
back because they communicate in a low frequency
that is undetectable by normal human ears.
Rick comes home that night, and accidentally hits
Abigail. He is later swimming, when a loud thud
is heard outside. Tally has come to visit him.
With her, several guards also approach the house.
It turns out that she has killed her husband. The
soldiers sedate Tally and try to take Rick too,
but he easily kills them all with his newfound
power. He only stops when Abigail asks him to.
The officials then take him to the facility and
keep him in a glass cell. Rick is now ready to
be sent to Titan, but his emotional attachment
with Abigail and Lucas stops him from proceeding,
so the professor asks Abigail to inject
him with a compound to erase his memories.
Abigail obliges and gives him
the shot. Rick shakes his head,
suggesting that he doesn’t want to forget her.
Abigail comes out of the cell, takes Lucas and
Dr. Freya, and runs away, as it turns out she gave
him a different compound to help him escape.
Rick pretends to be unconscious and kills a
soldier. The others are alerted, but his evolved
abilities help him escape easily. Rick meets his
wife and son in one of the labs, but is quickly
surrounded by soldiers. The professor explains
to Abagail that Rick’s evolution is irreversible,
and he cannot go back to being human now. His
only way to survive is to go to Titan. Seeing
that she has completely lost her old husband,
Abigail finally agrees to let him go away,
for the sake of humanity and its survival.
In the next scene, we see them in an airplane.
Rick lies in a body bag and is being taken to
be sent to Titan. Cut to a few months later,
the professor has been arrested for using
unethical methods. Abigail and Freya have taken
over the Titan II facility. Lucas calls his mother
outside to make her look at the clear night sky.
Somewhere far away in the galaxy, we see
Rick standing on the mountains of Titan.
He has fully adapted to its environment. He
spreads his webbed arms and flies in its sky.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on notifications,
and leave a like to help the channel
out. Thank you for watching.